Well,
we have an article in last month's art
news about museums in China,
and there's hundreds of them coming all
over China,
but they're not run the same way that
Western museums are run.
The difference is that the people
running western museums are coming out
of a long history of kind of established
profession,
and they're kind of,
in China,
the standards are different,
so maybe the way they choose exhibitions
is different.
Maybe the way they approach the idea
that there should be climate control is
different.
Maybe the way that somebody gets into
the position of director is different
because maybe it's more political.
Maybe there's more government control of
what's going on in the exhibitions.